what's up you guys welcome back to my
flickers of fears my movie review series
so the movie uh i'm talking about today
is this is one i've been wanting to see
for like a really long time because i
really really like
seeing ones that were kind of i don't
know if this was like super super
divisive but it did seem like there were
kind of two camps where you either like
loved it or hated it or some people like
loved it until the end which they hated
which i'll get into in a little bit now
this is a movie called come true
billed as a sci-fi horror although i'm
not sure i'd call it that but i'm not
really
sure what else i'd call it i guess it
has some like sort of sci-fi elements to
it um but this movie is kind of like a
waking nightmare i guess so this came
out in 2020 uh it's canadian
and it debuted at the fantasia film
festival back in 2020 and again it
seemed like very popular at that
festival but also one of the more
divisive ones
uh i kind of feel like mostly most of
the criticism i saw of it like some
people thought it was like slow and
pretentious i didn't find it pretentious
i don't know if that means i'm
pretentious i don't really know i didn't
find it that i thought it was like
really cool um and a lot of people
really really did not [ __ ] with the
ending they thought that the ending like
negated everything that came before it
in the movie which again i didn't find
that either but everyone's opinion you
know everyone's tells their own opinion
obviously however
me and like several other i know that's
not grammatically correct
i and several other reviewers because
this got actually like pretty much 80 90
like critical acclaim i found this a
profoundly
unsettling
i want to say like almost a masterpiece
i
loved this i loved everything about this
movie i just loved the whole like vibe
of it i just got sucked right in um and
i was just like glued to the screen the
whole [ __ ] time i kind of feel like
you'll be into this
if you like i mean maybe you won't but i
kind of feel like if you're into david
lynch or if you're into it's not super
lynchian but if you see it you'll know
what i'm talking about um if you're into
like philip k dick uh type stuff or
anything having to do with sort of like
cinema of the subconscious type thing
like there's a lot of that like jungian
type of stuff going on i think you'll be
into it if you like that
so come true was written directed
edited
and mostly scored by anthony scott burns
who is a filmmaker visual effects artist
and also a musician he has done like a
bunch of stuff in the past he actually
was the effects supervisor on the 2012
movie the last will and testament of
rosalind lee which is great if you
haven't seen it
um he directed the father's day segment
from holidays that 2016 anthology horror
movie and in 2018 he did a movie called
our house which seemed like it got like
a lot of critical acclaim i don't think
i've seen that um but i'll definitely be
checking it out like after i've seen
this because like i said i really i
loved this i thought this was great okay
i'm gonna say that come true
like most most films but i kind of feel
like maybe more so with this one this is
much better going into it with
absolutely like no foreknowledge of
where it's headed or what's going on
because there's it's kind of like a
mystery sort of
um so it's kind of better not to know
what's happening
but uh that said in order to have a kind
of a proper discussion about the movie
i'm gonna have to like low-key spoil
some stuff about it so
kind of be warned this is your warning
right now uh this is also a movie that's
definitely gonna need a second watch and
i'm actually kind of like i'm gonna
re-watch it like soon because i was
really into this and this is one of the
movies this is one of those movies that
i want to like nerd out about you know
what i mean and that's i don't really
find a lot of those anymore but yeah
this is one that i definitely want to
nerd out about and hear everybody's like
theories and [ __ ] like that
so what we have julia sarah stone uh she
plays an 18 year old young woman named
sarah dunn
now at the beginning of the movie sarah
she seems like she's essentially
homeless
like she sleeps on a slide like in the
park with her backpack and her uh you
know she has like a sleeping bag
and she has a house but she seemed to
like only sneak back in there when her
mom leaves like she watches for her mom
to leave and then she kind of climbs
back in her window and like gets clean
clothes and showers and like steals some
toast and whatever and then leaves again
so we don't know and i don't think it's
ever really explained like why she's
avoiding her mom and we don't know if
she has a dad or anything like that the
only person you see like in one scene is
like her mom
maybe two scenes uh but yeah she's
avoiding her and you don't really know
why
so it's also left unclear what year this
is taking place in like her mom's car
like some of the technology like when
you get later on into the sleep study
portion of the film like the technology
that they're using [ __ ] like that like
some of the fashions
seems to kind of vaguely suggest the
1980s maybe early 90s maybe even late
70s it's hard to tell but sarah has like
a modern iphone so
it's it's sort of like one of those
things where it's
it's almost seems like it deliberately
wants to cause like a
sense of sort of like dream like
disconnect
uh you know from the very start of the
film to kind of like put you off balance
a little bit and the theme of it the
vibe of it really comes through more
with sort of like this desaturated color
scheme which looks very
cold and like sort of off-putting um
there's a lot of use of like flickering
like old-school like uh you know like
old-school crt monitors like that kind
of imagery and the sort of synthy
score which is like really eerie so like
i said it has like a weird
80s vibe but not like an overt like neon
blah blah like 80s vibe it's like a
really it's you'll you'll know if you
see it it's like it's really cool i
really really dug the the vibe of this
so sarah has been having kind of a hard
time sleeping not just because she's
like sleeping in a park all the time or
like crashing at friends houses or
whatever uh because every time she sort
of like drips off or falls asleep she
has these really really like disquieting
nightmares
that kind of consist of i mean the
nightmare images in this are great i i
just loved this whole like [ __ ] thing
but they're almost kind of like it's
almost kind of like the cameras like
moving down these halls and there's like
these weird like architecture type
things and there's all these like
shadowy figures like parts of bodies and
stuff but there's always like a shadowy
figure at the end with like these kind
of glowing white eyes now these
nightmare sequences i think are like one
of the highlights of the film and they
legit creeped me the [ __ ] out i mean
they're super super creepy they might
not like do the same thing for you but i
found them like really really intensely
intensely creepy
now because she's as i said essentially
homeless and she needs money and she
needs like a better place to sleep than
the park
she finds that she sees this flyer like
in a coffee shop
for a sleep study like you know if
you're having trouble sleeping or having
nightmares or whatever um you know we're
doing the sleep study it's 12 an hour
you just come there sleep there they're
gonna monitor you and it's like two
months or whatever
so she enters the study
um now the true purpose of this study is
most scientific studies uh they don't
really tell you like what it's for so
she does ask and she's just kind of like
hey asking the technicians like what is
this studying and they're like yeah we
can't tell you that which like i said
that's pretty standard protocol and a
scientific thing
now she does meet a handful of other
people that are undergoing the study um
four men and then there's one other
woman besides her who's a woman named
emily and she kind of asks why more men
than women why is it for men and two
women and you know the woman says the
the technician says i can't tell you
that either so you know that might be
significant i'm not entirely sure
but emily shares a room with her
so
basically what they do is they put these
kind of like quilted white suits like on
them and they have like all these wires
and things that are like attached to
them and then they wear this sort of
like weird padded helmet it kind of
looks like a brain it's kind of cool
looking actually this padded helmet and
that transfers the data to the
scientists you know in the other room
while the subjects are sleeping so like
i said they sleep there every night and
they monitor them and then the next
morning they give them like an exit
interview and then they go about their
day and then they come back the
following day so sarah's doing this
study the first night or two go just
fine she actually feels rested for a
while she has nightmares but nothing too
upsetting but one morning after doing
her exit interview with some of the
people that are running the study kind
of like the underlings like the main
doctor that's running it um this guy
with these big george romero glasses
which i thought was very funny i was
like i wonder is that deliberate like a
deliberate homage to george romero maybe
it does exactly look like george
romero's glasses but he's like not there
all the time so i guess like his
underlings i guess they're graduate
students or whatever so maybe they're
kind of like going against the protocol
a little bit or they're doing their own
kind of [ __ ]
so uh so this is one of those times so
during this exit interview like the
people show her
these photographs like they're kind of
hazy looking
but they seem to suggest the same images
that she saw in her dream
now for the most part she's kind of
looking at him and she looks like a
little bit uneasy but then she tells
them well i don't really feel that much
looking at them i can't really tell what
most of them are
but then they kind of like turn over the
last one and she has a panic attack
because this last one you can pretty
much see like i said it's kind of hazy
but you can see that it's like this
shadow figure that she's been seeing in
her nightmares
so after she has the panic attack she's
basically like okay i gotta quit this
study because you guys are [ __ ] with
my mind and i don't like it
now while this is going on sarah also
appears to be being stalked by this
young man with beard and glasses who for
a second i thought was daniel radcliffe
he looks like what's like in the first
scene like she sees them like in a
bookstore or something like that i was
like is that daniel radcliffe it's not
but it does like look a lot like him
now she discovers she sees him like in
the movie theater she's in the bookstore
she's like i think this dude is like
following me and that's like creepy as
[ __ ] but she soon finds out that this is
another graduate student who's working
on the sleep study who she's not met yet
his name is jeremy but he actually goes
by riff he's named after like riff raff
like from the rocky horror picture show
because he's like the main doctor's igor
type character so that's why they call
him that now he seems to have a little
bit of a crush on sarah which like i
said from a scientific standpoint not
very ethical to like have a crush on one
of your test subjects but that's neither
here nor there until he he gets like way
out of bounds later on but yeah so
because he likes her she's basically
look i'm not going to continue the study
i want to quit it's [ __ ] with my mind
and she's like i'm not going to keep
doing it unless you tell me what it's
for and he's like i can't really do that
you know i'm not really allowed to tell
the test but subjects what we're testing
and she's like well then i'm not coming
back then
and he finally breaks down he's like
okay fine i'll tell you
so he takes her into the shows of the
monitor it's like basically what we do
is we have this technology that and you
probably have figured this out just from
the pictures they showed earlier that
that kind of transfers brain waves into
images that can be printed out so
they're like we're basically like
watching
people's dreams is what we're doing
and specifically it seems that jeremy is
really interested in studying this kind
of like shadow figure because he's like
this turns up in like a lot of people's
dreams he's like including my own and so
we're trying to like
you know figure out like why so many
people from different cultures and
things like that like dream about this
same thing because they find that
interesting
now as the story goes on this shadow
figure
seems to begin manifesting in the real
world
or at least there are a couple times
where it seems to be seen like outside
of people sleeping
there's one particular scene where it's
not sarah but it's like two of the other
guys that are doing the study like they
have
sort of like simultaneous sleep
paralysis sort of things where they see
um the shadow figure like in their room
like when their eyes are open and that
like transfers across so they can see
the room like it is in their feet and
everything like that and they both see
the same thing like at the same time and
it's like pretty freaky and then like
they sit up and their eyes are all white
and you're like holy [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
is going on is this thing like being
pulled out of the dream is that really
what the scientific studies for we don't
know
so sarah also kind of sees it
she's like in a laundromat and she you
can kind of see it in the background but
she doesn't see it and then like
it's implied that she sees it kind of
like up in front of her
and then she sort of has another like uh
episode and she kind of like passes out
for some undetermined amount of time and
then she gets woken up by this lady like
in the laundromat who looks like she's
blind like she has the white eyes too
and she says these boys were in here and
they took something from you
like while she was out now she kind of
like goes like that and her cell phone
is gone and she's like distraught about
this because that was kind of like her
lifeline to her friend and stuff like
that
now from there the movie starts to get
like more
amorphous i mean it's kind of it's not
surreal necessarily other than the
nightmare sequences but you know that
those are nightmare sequences so it's
not like surreal in the same sense that
you might be thinking it's because it's
like pretty straightforward but like the
plot of it becomes more amorphous the
mystery becomes more amorphous
the nightmares start getting like more
ominous like i said you know the the
shadow figure starts turning up
simultaneously like in the same way like
in a lot of people's dreams like you
know [ __ ] like that characters kind of
disappear without explanation like the
line between reality and dreams becomes
kind of more muddled and murky
you're not really sure what's going on
um and you're kind of left wondering how
much of what you're seeing is like
really happening or how much or is the
dream world like bleeding into reality
so if this gives you any indication of
the vibe of what what's happening here
uh the movie is actually divided into
four chapters and these are named after
jungian archetypes like the first part
is named persona uh the second part i
think is named anima and animus uh the
third one's called the shadow and the
fourth one is called the self i think
that's the order that they go in but so
that this is like a very young and
subconscious collective unconscious type
of uh thing and you can't really trust
anything that you see as like being real
so by the end which
people that didn't like this movie
really really hated the ending
uh because they thought as i said that
it negated the entire purpose of the
movie which i don't agree with but
that's but that's fine if that's your
opinion
uh but by the end like the events of
everything that happened in the film
prior to that have been recontextualized
and you really have to start to figure
out where exactly the break with reality
occurred
or and this is kind of a spoiler whether
the entire movie actually took place
inside sarah's subconscious or maybe
even inside the collective unconscious
so that's kind of where they're going
with it so this movie is absolutely not
for everyone that's for sure uh but for
me it kind of like hit all of my happy
places this was just kind of like
i don't know this is just one of those
movies that just hit every single thing
i was just like yep yep yep yep yep i
love i love it i love it uh the whole
kind of like look and feel of it like
just drew me in right away and the whole
thing was so immersive
that i just like couldn't even like look
away from it just like the visuals of it
was just so cool like so stunning and
like so my thing that you know i just
was sitting there like watching and it's
you know it's not a long movie it's not
short it's an hour and 45 minutes but i
was just kind of like so so into it and
it's definitely one of the eeriest
movies that i've ever watched it really
kind of gave me this
unsettled kind of like weirded out sort
of feeling and even when there's like
long shots i didn't find it particularly
slow or pretentious or ponderous or
anything like that some people might i
guess that depends on the person
but i mean there are like kind of like
language shots with not a lot of
dialogue but
i don't know it didn't seem boring it
seemed like there was always something
moving something happening i really
liked it
i was just kind of like riveted by the
whole
unfolding mystery because like i said i
went into this not knowing a single
thing about it pretty much uh so just i
was like what the [ __ ] is going on now
what the [ __ ] is this oh my god so i'm
gonna say even though some people did
think the end was maybe like a cop out i
guess maybe i don't know i didn't feel
like that i think that the ending to me
seemed more like an invitation to kind
of dive deeper into the story and as i
said this is definitely one i'm gonna be
re-watching because there was a lot of
symbolism in there there was a lot of
implication in there there was a lot of
kind of like dream like logic and [ __ ]
like that and i love to puzzle [ __ ] out
like that um this is definitely a movie
that like i said i'm gonna be nerding
out about um you know and like reading
other people's interpretations of
because it's just one of those things
that really invites that kind of thing
and i really really like that so i'm
gonna say this is probably
since i've started doing the series i've
seen a lot of good movies on this series
i'm not gonna say i think this i liked
this
this is one of the best ones i've seen
lately i really really dug this a lot i
think the last one that made me this
happy that i've interviewed on this
series was maybe in fabric um which i
also adored but yeah this was a
completely different movie to that but i
really really dug this a lot so you know
your mileage may vary uh because like i
said this movie was like pretty divisive
so i don't know like some people might
like it some people might not but i
loved it um so you know if you've seen
it let me know what you thought about it
in the comments and we'll have a
discussion about it and that will do it
for this flickers of fear i will see you
guys on the next one bye